>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Cole: Good afternoon and
welcome to the Library of Congress
and to our Books and
Beyond presentation.
My name is John Cole, I'm the
director of the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress,
which is the reading
and literacy promotion arm.
It was created way back
in 1977 by Daniel Boorstin
when he was librarian of
Congress who thought the Library
of Congress should be doing more
to promote books and reading.
And this was before even the word
literacy was well-known or used.
And of course, when literacy became
a need in our society and something
to be promoted it was
natural that the Center
for the Book take that on.
Today, we are the administrators
of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Project and we're also involved
with other things at
a national level,
in particular the National
Book Festival.
And I hope that many of you know
about the National Book Festival.
I brought this program from last
year's festival to remind me
to give it a plug and also to
say that with the author program
of the National Book Festival,
which has been the responsibility
of the Center for the Book, along
with a pavilion of the states
which has people coming
from all over the country
to talk about books and reading.
It was through the Book Festival
that we've started getting more
interested in graphic novels.
And last year we really had quite --
well last two years we've
really had quite a program.
We do have a network of state
centers across the country
in every state that
help promote books,
reading, literacy and libraries.
And we also work with
nonprofit organizations.
Here at the Library of Congress
we feature talks such as this one
at our noontime Books and Beyond
which feature new books by authors
who are connected one way or another
with the Library of Congress,
often working as is this case with
today's speaker with our Prints
and Photographs Division
quite closely.
Our talks are all filmed
for later viewing
on the Library of Congress website.
So I'm asking you to please
turn off all things electronic.
I want to remind you of a couple of
handouts that are on the back table.
We have a schedule of
future talks in this series.
We also have the latest
issue of the Library
of Congress magazine
imaginatively called LCM,
which features the activities
of the Center for the Book.
And we also have a form we'd
appreciate that you would fill
out telling us how you first learned
about this program to help us keep
up the momentum of having from 12
to 20 of these talks each year.
However, today to introduce --
the plan would be for our speaker
to give a presentation, to make
a brief pause for any questions
and answers and then there
will be a book signing
at the conclusion right
here in this room.
So welcome again and I would
like to welcome Martha Kennedy,
a curator from the Prints
and Photographs Division,
to introduce our program.
And I'm also going to try to find
out from Martha what she is curator
of since I never seem
to get it right.
Would you like to include that
in your self-introduction Martha?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Martha Kennedy: Thank
you very much John.
Good afternoon, welcome.
My name is Martha Kennedy
and I'm a curator of popular
and applied graphic art
here at the library.
And we -- that means I have
the great privilege of working
with original cartoon and comic art
and illustration art,
among other materials.
We are very thrilled in the
Prints and Photographs Division
to be cosponsoring this program
with the Center for the Book today.
And it's an honor for me to
introduce our speaker, Peter Kuper,
the author, artist of
the graphic novel Ruins.
Peter is an award-winning cartoonist
and illustrator and editor,
art director and arts educator.
He is a very versatile
and prolific artist.
He creates not only cartoons
and comics, graphic novels,
but also illustrations and cover art
for major magazines and newspapers.
Currently he is all a visiting
professor at Harvard University.
Peter was born in Summit, New
Jersey, grew up in Cleveland, Ohio,
attended Kent State University, then
came to New York City and studied
at the Art Students League
and the Pratt Institute.
Oh dear, I messed something up.
He and his friend and
fellow cartoonist,
Seth Tobocman cofounded the Politics
Graphics magazine World War 3
illustrated in 1979 and
it is still going strong.
Peter is well-known for writing
and drawing Mad Magazine Spy
Versus Spy also for
more than 18 years now.
He's created more than
a dozen graphic novels,
including The System,
Sticks and Stones,
Adaptation to Franz Kafka's The
Metamorphosis and Give It Up,
and a wonderful
semi-autobiographical graphic novel
called Stop Forgetting to Remember.
Peter received a journalism
award from the Society
of Newspaper Designers in 2001,
two gold medals and a silver medal
from the Society of
Illustrators in New York City.
His work has been published
and exhibited internationally
and the library is fortunate
to hold examples of his strong
and vivid drawings and prints in
Prints and Photographs Division.
He remains remarkably modest in
light of his many accomplishments
about which more could be said,
but for the moment please help me
welcome Peter Kuper, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Kuper: I followed
that fight up to the part
where you said delightfully
modest and I thought
that doesn't sound familiar.
So thank you so much for coming
and thank you to the library
for having me, it's
really an honor to be here.
And we first connected back in 2001,
after 9/11 when there was an art
show in New York that had a number
of pieces that were about 9/11
and I was really grateful to make
that connection and stay in
touch throughout the years.
So I'm going to give you
a little bit of history
and I hope you'll follow along with
me and I won't bore you to death.
So some of my history or
maybe all of our history.
I grew up in the 60's and
was sort of at the tail end
of experiencing the Vietnam
War and the hippie movement
and all these things that I
really felt like I missed out on
and not the war so much
as the hippie movement.
But there's this history that we all
seem to have that I get to capture
in every issue of Mad
Magazine with Spy Versus Spy,
our tendency towards
some form of destruction.
And we've been capturing our
history in art and in fact,
it's one of the few
things that remains
to indicate where we came from.
There's no music left unfortunately
from those days, those early days.
And there has been a tendency --
there's our early shopping habits
and that's actually Banksy he
put that up at the British Museum
and it stayed up for a couple weeks
before anybody realized it wasn't
part of the exhibit.
Got to love Banksy.
So one of the things that
has seemed to happen also is
that artists are drawn to
talk about real life events.
And somebody like Goya who to
his detriment did this series
of etchings, Disasters of War,
and paintings talking
about what was going on.
And he was, you know, sort of the
court painter and he didn't have
to be doing this and it
didn't help his career along.
The same with Daumier who
his portrait of the King
in France got him a
six-month jail time.
So there has been this aspect of art
that has always wanted to reach out
and comment on the
pillars of society
like Boss Tweed, this
is Thomas Nast.
And famously his drawing
of Boss Tweed helped
the customs identify him
when Boss Tweed fled the country
having pretty much ransacked the
treasury of New York and he ended
up dying penniless in jail, woohoo.
Thomas Nast also developed
the elephant and the donkey
as our Democratic and
Republican symbols.
He also did the first
image of Santa Claus,
but some very wise people felt that
a little more color would be nice
and so the Coca-Cola Company,
figuring that would be perfect
to work with their logo.
That's why we have a red
and white Santa Claus.
The English tried to change it
to green and white more recently
and nobody was buying it,
Coke is just too popular.
So there were magazines also
that were giving a forum
to political artists like the
Masses and they too were shut
down when Woodrow Wilson had
promised us not to go into war
and then did and there was a whole
movement against work like this.
This is the perfect
soldier by Robert Miner.
And Simplicissimus in Germany
which gave a voice to artists
like Kathe Kollwitz
and John Hartfield.
And, you know, it threatened
their lives
to do images like this in the 30's.
George Gross, many of them, in
fact probably all them had to flee
in order to avoid concentration
camps.
Picasso got into the act too
with Guernica about the bombing
of a Spanish town in Spain,
Spanish town in Spain.
And Diego Rivera's a mural
Man at the Crossroads,
which he curiously was hired
by Rockefeller to do it
at the Rockefeller Center.
And I don't know if
you know this story,
but he put in this little
image of Lenin under the wing
and Rockefeller said, you've
got to take out, you know,
the biggest communist
is in the lobby
of the biggest capitalist
you've got to take that out.
And Diego, who is getting a
hard time from his friends
for having taken on this commission
said, no and so Rockefeller paid him
and chiseled it off the wall.
There he is working on
one mural or another.
So you know art is used in many
directions, it's not always antiwar.
The government can use
it to direct people
into war and/or to support the war.
And, but then again there's
always some lefty popping
up with their little
commentary on even that.
So in the 50's there were war
comics that were being produced.
Harvey Kurtzman was out one
of the editors who did this
and he was really trying to do
comics that were for adults,
for soldiers in fact
talking about war as it was.
He was very concerned with being
accurate with all the armaments
that no one could call him
out and say that, you know,
it's a comic and, you know, it's
just sort of glossing over things.
This was also coming
from a company EC
that was doing pretty much a
whole series of amazing comics.
But this was in the 50's
around the time of McCarthyism
and there was a lot of scare
about well just everything,
including the fear that comics
would lead to delinquency.
And so there was a move by a guy
named Frederick Wertham he wrote an
article that caused a big uproar,
the seduction of the innocent.
And people decided that
comics were bad for children
that violent comics
would lead to violence.
We've heard this about
Dungeons and Dragons too,
this is an ongoing story.
And that led the industry to
say okay we'll self-censor,
please don't kill us
we'll self-censor.
And in that self-censoring with
the Comics Code they also agreed
to not have titles that included
words like weird and crypt and well,
you know, pretty much
everything that EC published.
And that knocked that line of comics
that was heading towards a whole
new possibility in the form
of more adult comics, it
knocked it out and it ushered
in superheroes in a big way.
The only one standing from the
EC Company was oddly enough Mad
Magazine, the most
subversive comic ever
which shows you what happens
when you censor things.
And Mad was a huge influence
on me, I grew up reading it
and the idea that, you know,
you could say these things
about the pillars of society
and make jokes and all.
But I was a little put off
when they made fun of hippies
because I thought wait a minute like
where do they stand on these issues.
I thought that they were left-wing
and then they were every wing.
Around the same time
Jules Feiffer who's got --
I believe his archives
are with the collection,
brilliant cartoonist who's
done pretty much everything.
Started to do a comic
strip in the Village Voice,
along with having been drafted
in the Korean War he came
up with the story of a boy
who's accidentally drafted,
which is how he felt, a
four-year-old is drafted.
And this made into an animated
film that won the Academy Award.
Along comes Underground Comics
which is basically the children
of Mad Magazine, Robert Crumb and
a number of people were coming
out with comics that really, really
didn't have the Comics Code on them
in any way, shape or form.
But one of the things I noted
from these comics was also
that they had a political sentiment
and the first things I heard
about environmental movement
and a number of antiwar things
in comics was coming
out of Underground.
So this was a kind of poster
that you'd see on a lot
of college walls in the late 60's.
And I love the idea that
art could have this impact
that people would put this out and
it was sort of like a rallying cry.
And I grew up in the 70's
and it was, you know,
I was hoping to do art and I
wished that I could do something
that had a happier face on it.
But somehow or another growing
up through the Vietnam
War it was very difficult
to ignore what was going
on behind that smile.
And when I was in art school Ronald
Reagan was just coming into office.
If you don't happen to
remember Ronald Reagan,
it's okay he may not
have recalled either.
But he promises a less
bureaucratic shadow government.
That's The Onion, love The Onion.
So with Ronald Reagan coming into
office, the Cold War in full effect,
the Iranian hostage crisis going on,
it looked like we were
headed towards war.
And, therefore, the title World War
3 illustrated seemed appropriate
for the magazine that my
friend, Seth, and I started.
We started this because the
Underground Comics scene had
collapsed and that we were
doing politically minded comics
and we saw political art around in
New York City where we were going
to school and we wanted
to capture it.
Because it felt like this wasn't
showing up in mainstream media
and it was being washed away at the
first rain when the posters fell
down or the spray painted
washed off the wall.
And this is at the same exact
time that Francoise Mouly
and Art Spiegelman started Raw,
in fact we shared staplers
on our first issue.
And inside of Raw was this
little booklet called Maus,
which certainly comic people
like myself noted and loved
in its chapter by chapter
development.
So World War 3 started talking about
world war, you know, like world war
and the fear of World War 3.
And we realized pretty quickly
though that what was going
on in the streets of New York
was something that we could talk
about that was based
on personal experience.
And, therefore, you know, you
could argue with the details of it,
but it was based on something that
we experienced firsthand as opposed
to something that we might have
read in the paper or in a book.
And year after year more and
more people came to the magazine
and seemed to be inclined to join us
and there were more editors
involved, so it wasn't just two
of us putting it together and
trying to kill each other.
And one of the secrets of
our success I've concluded
over the years is that our
success was our failure,
which is that we've
never made any money.
Everybody that works on the magazine
does so for free and that --
but what it has provided
is a payment of form
which is an opportunity to
talk about urgent issues
that we're desperate to get down on
paper and to identify the history
that may be an unspoken
or unwritten history.
And this is expanded
out into other projects
that we've done art shows, murals.
This was a big show
that we had at Exit Art.
I first connected with the Library
of Congress when they saw a show
that was at the same
gallery on 9/11.
And this is all part of -- this
was our 30th anniversary art show
and this is our 35th
anniversary anthology.
We've actually had three
anthologies already along
with the regular issues and we're
still publishing to this day.
I'm working on the new issue
and I coedited the last one.
One of the other wonderful things
that has happened is this has
created an environment for artists
to be able to do their
work and get published.
And has led a number of
the people involved to do,
collectively do other graphic novels
like Studs Terkel Working
which we adapted.
One of the people who had their
work published here did Seven Miles
a Second.
And this is just a series of graphic
novels that came out of the pages
of World War 3 originally
by cartoonists and editors
who were involved in the magazine.
And it's given us -- again,
this proving ground because it's
so hard sometimes to
get the sense of self,
an idea that you can do comics.
And especially with
people in some cases
who were doing their very
first comics like Sabrina Jones
in World War 3 and developed
herself in the pages of the magazine
with our associative
editing and all.
I always felt kind
of ripped off growing
up like oh my generation
arrives just, you know,
we get to the beach just in
time for waves to wash up
and we missed the beat generation,
we missed the hippie
movement, summer of love.
But actually what we concluded
is, you know, these are things
that they were developed
by some group of people
and we too are a group
of people and so we sort
of developed our own
little of sorts.
And that's my coeditor one of his
books and his most recent book.
Eric Drucker, who also
I believe is in library.
Flood I believe is
here and Blood Song,
these are incredible graphic novels,
I recommend all of them to you.
I know a lot is going by.
So before I get into my own work
I'll just give you a quick rundown
on the secrets of the
graphic novelist.
This is the boy's club
version because I'm a boy.
So it's very important
when you're growing
up to have some dedicated time
to read comics and look at them.
This seems to be a consistency
between cartoonists is the
missing the sports gene,
that's the fifth quarter
they're playing by the way.
Of course, life experiences
to draw upon
in your work are very important.
You must believe in yourself.
That would be young Chris
Ware probably or fill
in the blank, a famous cartoonist.
Some spiritual connection
I think is important.
And ultimately, being excited
about a career in the arts.
So one of my earliest graphic novels
was an adaptation of the jungle.
And I did this in stencils
and spray paint
which was a very odd
form for comics.
And I also tried to apply some
of the art influences I had,
a little Russian constructivism
and German expressionism to do some
of the imagery which I thought that
could fit very much into comics.
Another big influence
on me has been travel,
getting to see many parts the world
has given me a connection with a lot
of the subject matter
that I want to talk about.
I was in New Guinea and it's helped
me develop a lot of ways of drawing
that I wouldn't have
otherwise maybe gone
down if I had just
worked consistently
where you're being told you have
to have a style and you have
to have a certain look and a
certain way of doing things
and I just did whatever I
wanted in my sketchbook.
And that has served me very well
in many different ways and has led
down a lot of different paths.
Although, even when I'm sitting
on a beach in some beautiful place
in Mexico or Thailand or
Indonesia I seem to always return
to my concerns about world events.
This is a book I did crazily for DC
Vertigo, which is the same people
who did Batman and Superman.
An editor came there and asked me if
I had any ideas and I had this idea
about sort of the connective
tissue between all of us.
And I thought I would
do it is a wordless book
because among other
things, even stylistically,
I wanted to confound
people who felt the comics,
they understood what comics
were and had dismissed them.
So comics have word balloons
and comics have this
certain kind of muscly style.
And so I took those things away
and the subject matter I
tried to make more adult.
And really when, you know, comics
are a very interactive medium.
In fact, I think there's a
high level of visual literacy
that is asked of the
reader and that's part
of why they're often dismissed.
You know, people say if
they look at fine art
and they don't understand they think
they're stupid, but if they look
at comics don't understand they
think the artist is stupid.
And it seems to quote
Chris Ware I believe.
And anyway, this is a
little bit of my approach.
So actually I cut stencils for my
pencils and there's holes in papers
which are they sprayed with
red paint and black paint
from cans not airbrush
and then watercolor
and a little color pencil.
Here's another one.
And I got to utilize the
information I got from traveling
to these distant places
where I went to rain forests
where it wasn't raining necessarily.
The people at Mad saw what I
was doing with wordless comics
and asked me if I wanted to
try out for Spy Versus Spy
and my reaction was almost an
immediate no because I'm an idiot.
And they recognized the idiocy in me
and thought you'd be a
perfect member of the gang.
And so I did a sample and I realized
when I did this how much the creator
of Spy Versus Spy, Antonio Prohias,
a Cuban artist, had influenced me.
And I remember looking
at those spies and trying
to decipher the puzzle and
it was just and it ended
up being part of my
DNA a little bit.
So when I did my tryout I
thought I would do something
that would confound them.
I wasn't going to try and look like
Prohias, so I did it in stencils
and spray paint and it turned out
that's what they were looking for
and I'm now in my nearly, coming
into two decades of doing it.
I also really enjoy exploring all
the things you can do with comics
and one of them is adaptations
and autobiography and journalism.
And a friend of mine used to war
Kafka stories while over beers
and we would have a good laugh
over the dark humor in his work.
And I did one collection and
then later thought, you know,
the Metamorphosis, that's the
cover of the original Metamorphosis
from 1915 and I thought
I would give that a go.
But before I did that I actually had
the opportunity to do a treehouse
of horror for the Simpsons.
And I thought what if.
Oh, but it was all
a dream or was it.
D'oh with echo and of
course, Lisa suggesting
that he read Charlotte's Web.
So before I started the
Metamorphosis I decided to look back
at what comics were being
produced at that time
and there's a brilliant
cartoonist, Windsor Winsor McCay,
did Little Nemo in Slumberland
actually predating what Kafka did.
Especially a strip on
Dream of the Rarebit Fiend
which had this remarkable
surreal quality to it.
And though he always
allowed people to wake
up at the end, this is from 1913.
It says Silas on there that was his
pen name because he was so prolific,
he was working for multiple
papers and so he took a pen name.
But the period quality mixed with
the tone of the work it was --
perhaps this was just the zeitgeist
of the world, but I always wondered
if Kafka had seen these comics.
So that's my cover of Metamorphosis.
Now Kafka did say, whatever you
do don't put the bug on the cover,
but he also told the executor of
his estate [inaudible] to burn all
of his unpublished
manuscripts and I figured
if his friend could ignore him
I might do a little of the same.
So I decided to do it in
something called scratchboard
which would approximate something
like woodcut though it allowed me
to have the much more
complicated work
that I needed to do
with pen and ink.
And I wanted to get the feeling of
that time period and I generally try
to serve the story, whatever that
may be with the style and not worry
about I'm going to do
the style that I do
and then it's going
to fit around me.
But rather it's nice that my
style happens to fit with Kafka
and that's probably
why I was drawn to it.
So the events from back
then are still happening
and I've been given the opportunity
to illustrate them
in many publications.
And I seem to be the go to
guy for stress and concern.
It's something I can, I
don't know there's a lot
of oomph I can get behind this kind
of imagery that I never was able
to do when I was doing
something that was lighter.
So when George Bush came
into office around that time
and that pretty quickly led to a
point in time with September 11th.
This is an image that actually the
library has in their collection.
And it was really a time when
I understood the importance
of alternative media because it was
next to impossible to do any imagery
that was counter to the
general voice of government,
which was we need to go and
kill more people elsewhere
in order to address the attack.
And, you know, I understood
the sentiment,
but the sort of aimless
sense of where we had to go.
And this is also a time when people
like Art Spiegelman who did Maus,
won a Pulitzer Prize, and
had trouble getting his work
in mainstream media, he couldn't get
his work published in the New Yorker
where he had been an editor in fact
because it was really a distinct
shutdown on what was being said.
This is the cover of
the issue of World War 3
that we did before we went into
Iraq where it was extremely clear
to a large number of us in
fact, millions that the war
in Iraq was a terrible idea.
That we were going to deeply
regret and yes it was very much
like Vietnam, contrary to what
was being suggested in the media.
And thanks to people like Janet
Malcolm who helped us believe
that there were weapons of mass
destruction that, you know,
the next smoking gun
would be the form
of a nuclear weapon headed our way.
And so we sent a whole lot
of people into harm's way
and we've pretty much
outstripped the number of people
that were killed, Americans that
is that were killed in 9/11,
let alone the hundreds of
thousands of people who were killed
in various other countries.
This is one of my responses.
Oddly enough, one of my first
jobs is an inker on Richie Rich
and I knew it would
come in handy one day.
Oh sorry, cha-ching.
So these were the kind of
images that we were doing.
Yes, they were -- we felt the strain
of our constitution under attack.
This is actually something
I did for Time Magazine.
There was a moment in time there
where mainstream publications
were actually running articles
that were discussing these things.
The message that was seeming to come
from government was,
you know, get duct tape.
And I don't know if you
remember this symbol
for the Total Information
Awareness Office.
It was run by John Poindexter and
the name seemed vaguely familiar.
I remembered it was from
the Iran-Contra hearings
where he was caught up in that
scandal and he was making a return,
but this symbol scared
people too much
and they took it away
pretty quickly.
Although perhaps what was put in
motion is still with us today.
You may also recall libraries
were under surveillance
and librarians were told they had a
gag rule that they could not speak
about what -- that
individuals were taking
out books were being
under surveillance.
And if you took out a book
that had the word bomb in it
like I got bombed last weekend
say, but I had a mild hangover
and I'm okay that that
was being tracked.
And it seemed to be what
is a lot of our privacy.
Though curiously a recent study said
that about 90% of the fake bombs
and other weaponry
that they tried to put
through to test whether our TSA
was functioning got through.
So apparently [inaudible],
sorry for all the sounds,
I forgot about all my sound
effects I'll lower them a little.
But maybe we should all jump
in our seats when we think
about gun control in this
country and what exactly leads it.
And the lack of healthcare or, you
know, there's been a lot of attempts
to get healthcare, but there
seems to be a lot of roadblocks
on that basic idea and
education and other things.
We want less government
apparently, but we want more debt.
And perpetually hoping
there's a plan.
I know I am, I know there's a lot
of people that are really hoping
that there's a plan for
these various incursions.
Makes you kind of wish for
the good old days instead
of things being blown up they were
just well I won't even go there.
So there was that moment in
time that lasted quite a while.
This was the image that I put
forward to the New York Times
for an article on Abu Ghraib
about four days after the event.
They said you know that that is
such an overused symbol and it's
like it's just become a
symbol how can it be overused.
This is what I did get through,
which isn't like a total, you know,
like missed the boat
completely, but it was talking
about these connections that
I wanted to put in the work.
So censorship doesn't
necessarily come in the form
of an absolutely you can't do it,
it's more like well
that's not really working
or they killed the article
that I did for Time Magazine.
I illustrated a piece by Garrison
Keillor before we went into Iraq
where he was saying
this is a terrible idea
and they just killed
the article and my art.
Einstein was quoted as saying
that he doesn't know how
we'll fight World War 3,
but World War 4 will be
fought with sticks and stones.
And this inspired the
title of this book.
The notion that I got kind of
tired of drawing political figures
that I knew were going
to turn to dust
and people wouldn't even
necessarily remember who they were.
And so I decided to do something
that was more of an allegory.
Because I did wonder where
do we get leaders like this,
where do they come from and I
thought maybe they just get spit
out of a volcano somewhere
and they self-actualize.
And for some crazy reason we give
them power which they are more
than happy to take very
often to our detriment.
So in these next elections, thank
you Diebold, Diebold, it was a point
in time where I had been foaming
at the mouth for a good while
and I decided -- my wife and I had
talked about taking a sabbatical
for a year, we wanted our
daughter to get a second language
and I had lived in Israel when I
was 10, my father had a sabbatical.
And it was huge, both traumatic
and incredibly expanding experience
being thrown into a school
where I didn't speak the language
and I thought we should
do this for our daughter.
And we very randomly picked this
small town in Mexico Oaxaca.
I barely knew how to say the
name O-A-X-A-C-A Oaxaca really.
So there's my daughter at
nine, daughter there awe.
She's now in college
gulp that happened fast.
I thought it would be a great chance
to see other art and really kind
of get out of my head with all the
political work I've been doing.
This is a radish festival
every year, they carve radishes
into creches and things like that.
And I did get the opportunity
to spend a lot of time drawing
in my sketchbook and
beautiful scenery
and it became very mural like.
It was funny I didn't, I think
I understood where somebody
like Diego Rivera came from not
so much I was looking at his art
as I was looking at Mexico and
it seemed to be this synergy
and synthesis and simultaneity there
between the past and the present.
There goes my clicker again.
So we arrived in 2006 and
I noticed there was a lot
of as we made our way towards the
airport and we barely spoke Spanish.
And I asked the taxi driver who that
was and he's oh it's the governor
and apparently had
stolen the election.
And well I could read that actually.
Truth be told, we never word
offered anything but kindness
in our two years down there.
But it just happened that there
was a teacher strike going on
and this was an annual event that
had been going on for 25 years,
but the new governor
had decided instead
of giving them their normal pay
raise which was pretty meager
that he would try to just expel them
from the zocalo, the town square.
And he sent in police in the
middle of the night and instead
of expelling them it made
the strike much larger.
Other different unions joined
in and people poured into Oaxaca
and that eventually
people were getting shot
and federal troops arrived
when a single American
journalist was killed.
And written on their
shields is murderers,
two women I saw they
wrote that on the shields.
And I kept waiting for the
guys to rearrange the shield,
so it said have a nice
day or something
like that, but it never happened.
And amazingly, they let them
do this without attacking them.
So we ran away from, at least
somebody was happy you know.
I asked, I asked, she was okay.
But one of the things
I noticed when we were
down there was how much art
played a role in daily life
and this is during day of the dead.
And people would open up the
cemeteries and these places
that I always considered to be
a black and white sad experience
that everybody was crying,
it was always raining was this
happy music infested place.
And people did commentary about
the events and it just seemed
like everybody was an artist and
there was just art everywhere.
And it really felt like
it was part of society
and not something you
saw only in a museum.
And you could feel the spirit
of the past artist like Posada
who died penniless, did
all this political art,
but he did it in woodblock form and
it got reproduced again and again
and he's among the most
famous artists of Mexico now.
And here you see the
reflection of that kind of work.
Or Diego Rivera's murals which are
being replicated in ways like this
that was in the zocalo where they
were doing these hand done murals
that were describing what was
going on during their time.
But it might be more
appropriate to say that one
of the bigger influences on
the strike was Frida Kahlo
because women were the main force
behind the teacher strike and many
of the plans and the actions
were implemented by women.
And I found myself starting
to draw these things
and I realized I wasn't
trying to escape
from drawing political things I just
wanted a different political subject
matter to draw that had a little
more maybe light in it I'm not sure.
My version of light at least.
I love the backdrops, I'd be sitting
at a cafe and that would be my view.
There was a strike, there was
a march that happened one day
and my wife and I went down there
we were having a date and she --
my version of the date was we'd
go down there and I'll draw
and she was like okay honey.
And so we left and five minutes
after we departed the troops
attacked and we missed being rounded
up by a very small margin.
And I finished the drawing, I did
the bottom part of the drawing
down there and then I finished
the drawing with what I saw
on the internet when we got home.
And I was able to put
this into World War 3.
Again, I got 11 pages to
talk about what was going on
and nobody was interested
in doing that big of a story
in the mainstream publications.
I did end up in Mexican newspapers
as a result of the work I was doing.
And again, it was so
important to have outlets
like this, this alternative media.
And this turned into a book that
I did when I got back from Mexico
that included all of my sketch work.
So we arrived back in New York after
two years just in time for the crash
and for my career to take a
downward turn as magazines folded
and my illustration
career went thud.
And Obama was just coming into
office with a whole new set
of things being handed to him.
And unfortunately, yes we can't
which we made me over the years want
to return to Mexico and have a
little of some form of escape yet.
And it came in the form of this
graphic novel idea that percolated
for many, many years and I wanted
to capture the experience
that we had down there.
But I decided to do it in a
fictional account where I was able
to talk about the circumstances
and place my characters right
in the middle of things rather
than where we were at somewhat
of the periphery and this
way I wasn't tied to so many
of the specifics and I could
do things that I wanted.
And these characters
visited the various ruins
and have their experiences.
And I could talk about the
inner lives of various Mexicans
that we encountered and the events
that took place on those days only
with the characters being
dead in the middle of them.
Another aspect of it
is that while we were
down I'm a closet entomologist.
Before I got interested in comics
I wanted to, I was a bug fan.
And while we were down there it
was like a return to my childhood
because there were so many
insects in Mexico that my sense
that that's all disappearing
that environmentally it's changing
it seemed on hold in Mexico.
And one of the ways that
we connected with that was
with the monarch butterfly
where we raised monarchs
down there my daughter and I
and then we visited Michoacan
where they come down
by the millions.
At one point it was about in the
last 10 years a billion monarchs
made their way to this
forest and passed
through our world to get there.
Science does not actually know
how they know to get down there.
They've done all sorts
of different studies,
they figure that they're
sort of GPSing off the sun
and the electromagnetic
pulse of the earth.
People who tag monarchs, it was only
in 1975 that they first discovered
where they even went and
they found these tags,
these little stickers they put
on them down in this one area.
Of course the people down
there knew they were there,
but they were sort of a quiet thing.
But in one sanctuary
and there's five
of them 11 million
monarchs show up on
and it's a long road to get there.
So in the last 10 years.
The billion has actually
whittled down to 30 million.
And as is my want I had them pass
over, this particular monarch pass
over many a thing that
had double meaning.
New Orleans the ninth ward.
Easier for monarchs to cross
borders and sometimes towns
that were violent and
sometimes towns
that were just plain beautiful.
And the natural ways that
monarchs are also threatened.
But fortunately for monarchs
they are attracted to milkweed
and milkweed has a
poison that they survive,
but birds have learned to avoid.
There's even evolutionarily a
butterfly called the viceroy
that mimics the look of monarchs
even though it's very tasty
and it survived as a result.
So, you know, trying to imagine
what's going on in the mind
of the monarch in order to make
its way to 2,000 or 3,000 miles
and weighs a gram, travels
12 miles a day perhaps.
It's just a, you know, you have to
be in awe of life and our world.
And it even will go so far as
to go all the way down to Mexico
and then start to see it
continue on back and get as first
as Texas in one generation.
Also weirdly it manages to
initially the first generation lives
for a couple of weeks, the
second-generation maybe seven weeks
and then the third
lives for six months.
And how that even happens still
like wow entomologists discuss.
So seeing this world of ours has
made me consider our position in it
and the big questions of whether
hegemony is more important
than what may happen to
us as a result of that.
And whether our water supply
is secondary to our gas supply
and whether our forests
are necessary even.
And whether what happens in the
Arctic will happen on Wall Street.
And whether we can
formulate new ideas
to address these very,
very urgent issues.
Here's little weather report.
But for those of you that are
in New York never fear alternate
side parking will remain in effect.
So this idea that what
happens in one place happens
in another makes me want to roll
back the clock and return it
to things that once were.
And yes me worry, I do scream
and not just for the Beatles.
And as we come up on
this next election
and they're passing the torch
all these issues about who's red
and who's green, who's
red and who's blue.
The things that separate us
and the things that we talk
about that are our divisions are
so much less important
than what connects us.
Because we're really all on the
same path and where we started
and where we're going
is exactly the same.
There may be some people that
don't believe that, but it is so.
And so we can effect a change
that can cause catastrophic
things or repair.
We share this world with all these
other creatures and they don't have
that advantage, they just have
to live here they don't
get to make the changes.
And the clock is ticking
on that in a very big way.
But ultimately the thought I
would like to leave you with is
as we struggle together in this very
important job of survival be kind.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yeah if there's any questions I'd
be happy to answer them and if not,
I'd be happy to sign books.
Anybody? Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh it's the first comics
course that they've ever had,
it's with the visual
environmental studies program.
And I don't know I just got pulled
out of a hat much to
my happy surprise.
I've taught at the School of Visual
Arts in New York for 25 plus years,
so I guess somebody heard that.
But the students caused
this to happen
because there was pressure
developing to have classes
so some people wanted to do
their dissertations in comics.
And there was just this
percolating interest in the form.
And I always feel I'm incredibly
lucky that I seem like I'm
at the door a lot for book
festivals and situations like that
where the first interesting comics
it finally breaks through and I get
to go talk at a book festival
or in this case teach
students graphic novels.
And it's -- I happen to do a
single page comic every week.
One of my students said it was
the hardest class that he had
in all his time at Harvard
and I was like sorry,
it's the same class I teach at the
School of Visual Arts you know.
But it is so brilliant, the
students are so great to teach
that the five hour commute
each way once a week
from New York is totally
worth it to me.
I'm giddy about going up there
and my class is four hours
long and I run out of time.
It's, you know, I can't
explain it completely.
I used to have a much shorter
class and I ran out of things
in the first half hour, but the
students just provide a lot.
I have 12 students in the class
and I actually have to select them,
which is another tremendous boon.
So up to 40 students will apply for
the class and then I interview all
of them and then pick 12 and 12 is
the right number for four hours.
And I have them do assignments
that are things like based
on a dream that they had.
Interview somebody, so
there's comics journalism.
Autobiography and social
content and I keep shifting it.
There was a long time where
in my class I had them say
where were you 9/11 and
I watch progressively.
Let's see my mommy brought me
some cookies and I don't remember
and like okay, time to
drop that one what's next.
So it's an evolving thing in that
way which is exciting for me too.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The question was is the class
a mixture of students from art
and other disciplines and yes,
this year it's the
smallest number from art.
And I have computer
scientists, economists,
medieval studies students,
English majors.
I remember my very first class,
I'm in my third year there
and my first class, the very
first assignment somebody brought
in with a title in Latin and
I just thought I'm so screwed.
And one of the students said I
don't speak Latin what the hell does
that say and I was like saved.
So yeah I went from
feeling quite daunted by --
the other thing I was told
by the person who hired me.
Oh by the way, they're not a race of
super intelligent aliens, you know,
and I was like oh right, right
they're humans yeah, okay got it.
And it turns out yes they are,
they are hard workers
that's the notable thing.
They don't tend to miss class and
they tend to do all the assignments
which doesn't happen as often
in my other classes,
but generally speaking.
And it's really the future
of comics to me are people
who are coming from
other disciplines.
It's one of the things that's
happened with World War 3 is
that we've gotten a lot more
women [inaudible] my class
of 12 has 2 guys and it is so great
because the women will
lead the charge
into what's happening in the form.
And people from various
backgrounds not just a bunch
of nerdy white guys.
I've been going to comic conventions
my whole life since I was 11.
It used to be literally all guys
and pretty much all white guys
and that going to comic conventions
now the dynamic has changed
dramatically and as a result the
material that's being made has
changed dramatically.
And if you're not a comic reader,
just with a little searching you
can find something that will touch
on something that interests
you that from all areas.
There's civil rights
movement done in comics,
a lot of gay lesbian subject matter.
In fact, that seems to be
a huge arc I'm noticing
from the last alternative
convention I went to,
more gay superheroes
and things like that.
But really pretty much everything.
There's tremendous journalism
being done in comics.
Joe Sacco is an artist he's
tackled the Palestinian situation
and Sarajevo and India
and you name it.
And then you have, you know,
these pillars like Maus
that tackled the Holocaust, which
was obviously a huge breakthrough.
But there's subsequently been
a lot of other work by people
with a wide range of backgrounds.
And so if read at all you can
find something that will touch
on something that you will be
probably very interested in.
Fun Homes is a fairly recent
autobiography that was made
into a play I saw recently.
It was a brilliant, it won the Tony
award best play with good reason.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
You're looking at a very digital
piece right there and the coloring
on the monarch butterfly
section was digital.
I keep a huge component
of paper art in my work,
the same way I'm very big on print.
I love print and I
don't want to miss that.
But I would miss it if, you
know, I'm hoping it's kind
of like vinyl it's coming back.
But yeah, you know, I'm interested
in all those different tools.
I try to discourage it to some
extent in class because I want them
to at least start with hand-drawn
things and then they can find
out how it can be augmented
digitally.
Because I see a lot of not very good
drawing that's being masked by that
and I think there's a
lot of steps in between.
Am I out of time?
>> John Cole: We have time
for one more question.
>> Peter Kuper: Okay.
>> John Cole: All right.
>> Peter Kuper: Did
that answer [inaudible]?
>> I scared the question
away I'm sorry about that.
>> Peter Kuper: That's all
right, that's all right.
>> John Cole: Peter,
this has been wonderful,
we've been treated you realize
to a history of comic art.
We've learned the secrets
of a graphic novelist.
We slowly crept up on Peter's own
work and career and saw how it fit,
but also kind of where it's going.
And it's really been a wonderful
presentation for all of us and we'd
like to join hands and
thank you one more time.
>> Peter Kuper: Thank you.
Great, thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.